MAHIRI MWITA: The primary
purpose of the program
is to study the language,
the Swahili language,
in an environment
where the speakers are
native speakers of the language.
We offered the
two-year sequence here
that fulfills Princeton
University's language
requirement program.
To acquire proficiency, high
proficiency of the language,
it is very important
for us to take students
to the communities where
the language is spoken,
and we immerse them in the
culture and the language.
So the primary
purpose of the program
is to take them to East Africa,
so they can listen and hear
the language as they
learn it, and also
interact with the
people's culture.
LIA COITO: In Tanzania, I
think I'm pretty excited, more
than anything, to just be
immersed in a language.
I've never really had that.
Just in the fact here,
when you learn it,
you do it in a classroom.
You might do some exercises,
but it stops, and then
you talk with everyone
else in regular life,
whereas this is
really an immersion
into a cultural way
of life, and just
being able to be
surrounded by something new
and learning in the process.
MAHIRI MWITA: The second
purpose of the program
is to enable them to be
adaptable to the culture
of the Swahili people.
So to enable them to do
that, I plan activities
with the community whereby
they get out of the university
setting, so they can go outside
and interact with the people.
MATT GWIN: I
volunteered every day
at the orphanage, the
[? Chakawan ?] orphanage.
I developed a really
strong relationship
with a few the kids.
That was one of the
highlights of my trip,
was doing that every day.
ELISA VERA: I wanted
to just something that
wasn't going to be affiliated
with my major at all.
In a sense, like
one of those things
to just make sure that I'm
ultimately doing something
that I want to be
doing, and just
to experience
something different.
Why not learn Swahili?
BEN DOBKIN: I hope
to really understand
more about what
I see around here
as a comparison to what is
so different in Tanzania.
And I hope to understand
like a separate culture.
Being there for
almost two months,
I'll really get a great grasp
of like how people interact
and what the social norms are.
Being in a culture that's
so disparate from my own,
I think it will
enable me to open
my eyes to a different
way of thinking.
TARIKUA ERDA: So it's
great that Princeton
offers this opportunity.
And coming here and
spending a year here
has taught me that there's a
lot I don't know about myself
and my own country,
because when you get
plugged out of what you've
lived in for 19 years,
then you learn a lot of
new things about yourself
and that place that you are
in from another perspective.